Sam check it out okay yeah
I'm sure I'm shooting something today
was my first day sure okay so I don't
know anybody
and you know I'm on makeup right and you
know it's one of those trailers where
makeup and hair isn't the same thing you
know and the lady that's playing my um
girlfriend is in the makeup chair I'm in
The Hair Chair and she's Chinese and the
lady doing her makeup is also Asian okay
she goes and she has an accent she goes
I'm from China
which is fine yeah right I didn't find
when you say I can't say yeah you you
can't do an Asian accent I don't think I
should no I think you should try it's
called acting
it's like an acting okay
three Asians telling you it's okay yeah
this is your One path yes Sam do the
Asian accent
don't do this
too much power all right
so anyway she goes I'm from China I love
China
um that's what you said right away yeah
I said I love China and then I say um
you know what China is known for tick
tock and coven
and then I could feel the just the
energy Drift from the room oh bad joke
no chuckle not only a chuckle it felt
like I was getting canceled wow so then
the my girl doesn't say the girl that
playing me the Chinese like she just
leaves oh she did a face oh wow and then
her makeup artist this taller Asian lady
goes that was really rude
I go what I don't because he I didn't
know even know what I said God I feel
like every other thing I say is like the
weirdest thing they've ever heard by the
way he did know you you just told us
I didn't know what you they were angry
oh yeah you're right all right all right
so
um
yeah well you know sometimes you throw a
ball and you miss well you swing because
that could work in some rooms
I know we all laughed it wasn't even a
funny joke it was just like I didn't
know why I said it was early in the
morning it was six in the morning you
know you're a comic at six in the
morning they're not their normal self
anyway she goes I that was rude I go why
she's like I mean it's like we're
getting attacked oh yeah yeah I mean
because of that and how dare you say
that and we got in a fight wow so then I
had to go glad she stood up for her oh
[__] it wait Did you defend yourself or
you're more like oh I got it no I go you
know what because I'm because you know
I've been in trouble right for my mouth
yeah so I go you know I'm gonna play
this differently you know what I heard
what you said
and you know when I get you man I see it
from your point of view and you know me
and I shouldn't have said it and I
really apologize
you're just telling everyone you didn't
mean your apology she's gonna hear this
no
in it just because I'm doing this
you could use a smirk in your face
comedians can't sense
this is unacceptable unacceptable yeah
think of Sam yeah and then I had to go
to her she was sitting on set
and I was just leaning against the wall
because she was doing something on her
phone and I I was trying to like find
the right window and I you know
sorry
and she said you know what it's fine and
then I was out but that'd be great if
you gave her covid and then I then made
a tick tock about it
I I wanna I think let me ask you
something I think it's just Korean
Chinese beefing I don't I think that's
what you I don't think it's an Asian
thing
like I think you guys are just I think
eventually that beef is delicious though
yeah but if a white dude said it you get
in trouble right I don't think they
would like it out of my mouth no you
think they would complain I don't I my
jokes are really well structured and
thoughtful I don't have this problem but
I totally understand
yeah I know I know but uh I don't think
about it I admire I admire your balls
for just going for it but I I wasn't
even throwing it I thought like it's
gonna hit I just said it I got you know
we're trying to sports okay you have a
tick-tocking covet I just throw it out
there you know what I mean and then once
I said covet I could just feel the room
change
it's a bad joke I know no it's not even
a bad joke it's funny it's not a fun
yeah you were being silly I think I
think I think it's [__] up to get
actually bothered by that that's all I
wanted to hear yeah it's a little weird
to make us think of it they know that
you're a comedian Right Bingo yeah thank
you so much that's why I love you so
much man yeah no thank you so I got an
ally by the way I like that I like that
an ally is now a guy who supports racist
Sam is an ally I'm like I do support uh
ignorance and uh really dumb fat [__]
stupid jokes yes I am a all right but
you know but as a comic yeah you'll
always come to my side and I really
appreciate that right I just yeah I mean
who gets actually offended exactly and
also it's like we're doing a movie it's
a show you say good morning what's your
name I didn't say like hey Chinese
people created [__] covet I just open
with that yeah I said good morning nice
to work with you and all that stuff what
about you Gilbert you know what thank
you I if I was there to get that room
yeah I'm probably laughing
yeah that's why you're my boy dog but
then I'm gonna be like hey I think
you're gonna get fired from this job say
something wow because there's like a
Disney kids movie you're on you're just
like you know who started kovitz